honored walk walk walk walk is lon
chaney lon gene watches have 110 World's
Fair grand prizes twenty eight gold
medals and more honors for accuracy than
any other time fees lon gene the world's
most honored watch is made and
guaranteed by the lawn gene with no
watch company
it's time for the launching conosco as
television journal of the vital aces of
the are brought to you three times
weekly a presentation of the lawn gene
which nor what's company maker all lon
gene the world's most honored launch and
wit nor distinguished companions of the
world honored lon gene good evening this
is frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene Cronus cope mr. Lawrence critic
columnist for the new york world
telegram & sun and other Scripps Howard
newspapers and mr. william bradford huie
editor of the American mercury our
distinguished guest is the Honorable
Morris J Tobin United States Secretary
of Labor in this spontaneous and
unrehearsed discussion the opinions are
necessarily those of the speakers mr.
Tobin I believe that you've been
Secretary of Labor in the truman cabinet
for about three years is that right sir
that is correct mr. Joey and you are
from Massachusetts who may have born
lived there all my life tonight sir I
think that our people would like some of
your views on inflation there is of some
of us in the country who are are afraid
that labor unions are partially
responsible for our inflation now what
are your views on that ship well i would
say that labor unions have been most
cooperative in establishing a
stabilization program in the country
labor unions the AF of L in the CIO
appeared before Committees of Congress
recommending a control program that
would stop an inflation they agreed to
accept wage stabilization and I would
say that if there is one segment of the
economy that deserves praise for their
cooperation and support of the program
and the legislation that
for stabilization that credit should go
to the trade unionists of the country
well now mr. Tobin the leading unions
have escalator clauses their wages go up
as costs go up now when that happens and
costs increase prices go up again and
since there are only 16 million members
of labor unions and only a few of those
have escalator clauses wouldn't you say
that those who are have the escalator
clauses are profiting at the expense of
those who have it well any program has
to be approved by the wage stabilization
board and I would say that the formula
that has been laid down by the weight
stabilization board is one that will
protect the country from inflation
unless the cost of living advances
beyond its present level well mr. Tobin
mr. defenses defense mobilizer Wilson
child's e wilson estimated himself that
the the defense effort will take twenty
percent of our national product within
the next year or so now that means we
all have to consume less now if we all
have to consume less and if certain
members of the strong labor unions get
the same amount won't the other suffer
it doesn't mean that we will have to
consume less mr. fertig d at the present
time work and about seven and a half
percent of total national production is
going into defense it is estimated that
the maximum according to the figures
i've seen would be twenty percent is
near enough but the estimate i have is
eighteen percent but we must remember
that we had room for expansion within
the economy that we're going to have a
substantial increase in steel production
within a year and a half it will be up
twenty percent we're having a tremendous
expansion in
nah aluminium production and the most of
it being produced in the standby
facilities that were abandoned during
the war mr. toad robber facilities and
the like have been taken back but by
increased work we can the like with
existing facilities America could
superimpose upon the economy before
Korea twelve to fifteen percent i would
say mr. tobin no nation in the world has
ever increased its product production in
one year anything like that figure our
normal increase it be at the rate of two
and a half percent a year we might get
up to three or three and a half but
eighteen percent of twenty percent is
impossible and if that is impossible and
we must consume less and certainly if
there's a hot war we'll have to consume
less then escalator clauses are
definitely inflationary because
everybody has to pay more as wages go up
and prices go up and those few people
profit at the expense of the others
isn't that true well let's take a look
at some of the other factors that have
contributed to inflation our wholesale
commodity price index went up fifty-six
percent in a period of about three
months and as a financial editor you
know that that means a spot price not
all commodities the overall spot price
to the limited number of commodity a
very limited number not all come on
quite substantial it runs to about 50
items well I should think not much less
than there and in a short period of time
that went up fifty percent with no
controls of any kind whatsoever now the
increased productivity increases that
you refer to that the escalator clause
is based upon increased productivity
have been defended by mr. Wilson the
president of General Motors as not an
inflationary factor because he expects
through increased efficiency to have the
small and they are trivial increases
based on increased productivity
amounting to but very small sum each
year he expects an efficiency in his
operation to take up that increased
costs no neck
to sum up on this point sir do you
anticipate increased more inflation in
the country on the basis of the present
stabilization law unless it is amended
is recommended by the president I expect
to see a decided increase in the
inflation and in a slight decline last
month but we have not begun to feel the
full impact of the defense program as
has been pointed out by mr. fatigue and
that's going to be constantly on the
rise it's going to create a greater
purchasing power in the hands of more
workers there's going to be an increased
work week it's gradually going to go up
the scale and as a result with this
increased purchasing power unless there
are firm price controls we are headed
for inflation and the cost of living is
going to go up decidedly that's the next
point I want to make sure you as a
matter of fact you expect the cost of
living to go up unless the cost of
living under any circumstances I think
we will have a creeping inflation but
what I would like to avoid is a runaway
inflation and I believe that if the
amendments that have been proposed by
the president are enacted that we have
an excellent chance of stopping a
runaway inflation slowing it down to
creeping and you think that the labor
unions are are trying are doing that
part to forestall that inflation I do
think that they deserve the credit of
the support and approval from the people
of the country for their willingness to
submit their own salaries and wages to
await stabilization board lends a walk
out of the last board mr. Tobin because
they weren't to getting everything they
thought they should get they didn't
really cooperate a hundred percent did
they in a democracy cooperation works
two ways they did come back they had
strong differences as to the basis upon
which a basis upon which the white
stabilization board should be set up but
remember they did favor stabilization
whereas many other factors in the
economy
many of the big business people of the
country many big business people did try
to support a sound Stabilization program
and yet some of the most powerful big
business people of the country are
against controls of any kind whatsoever
but you'll forget the state to mr.
secretary that the attitude of people
who are against controls is simply this
that inflation is caused by an increased
supply of money and if the government
this is the only one who can increase
the supply of money increases it there
will be higher prices whether there are
price controls and not price controls
never work when the government inflates
the monies mr. Secretariat no I'd like
to make the money in circulation
increased all during the last war but we
had a most effective consent of controls
that resulted in but a slight creeping
inflation during World War number two as
contrasted with World War number one
when we had one of the wildest
inflation's that America has ever seen
World War two black markets and
unavailability of materials or lack
markets came and a very latter end of
the war the black markets became rampant
i would say after the termination of the
european phase up to the time that
controls no Mike Dow secretary November
of night let's be honest about meat meat
was deliberately held off the mock meat
was deliberately held off the market in
the month the whole month of October of
1946 there is no question about it you
could travel from one end of America to
the other and you couldn't find me to
the counter I've heard that excuse
before mr. secretary but all I want to
say something outside to you he couldn't
get soap and the day after controls were
taken off there wasn't a store in
America that didn't have all the soap
that the American people wanted let me
ask one last cry was a great strike pool
at that time and it was most unfortunate
and created a great inflation there were
tens of thousands of people involved in
the meat process they all didn't enter
into a collusion in strike and the
President himself President Truman
himself was forced to say that price
controls don't work on meat and they
don't work on anything
when you need the mr. secretary dists
trikes ever perpetrated by big business
in America when they were bound that
they were going to get controls off and
they did hold off commodity out to
commodity that did appear on the shelves
of American grocery stores the moment
that the controls were taken off and
that was in the month of October 90
November 1946 oh thank you so much for
being with us this evening the editorial
board for this edition of the launching
krona scope was mr. Lawrence fretting
and the mister william bradford huie our
distinguished guest was the Honorable
Morris J Tobin United States Secretary
of Labor